on a vu nos parents vivre d'une manière
assez pénible et nous on ne voudrait pas
et que nos parents aussi ne voudrais pas
nous à vivre comme ils ont vécu
je m'appelle à auguste jeunes j'apparais
dans la vidéo on tournait à noël 66
les jeunes skieurs sont d'esker un peu
inhabituel ils sont différents c'est
parce qu'ils sont ici chez eux ce sont
de jeunes paysans de la montagne ça vous
plairait de faire du petit oubli à
l'époque de la vidéo j'avais 20 ans
aujourd'hui j'ai 75 ans mais ça va
depuis le tournage tu avais complètement
oubliée ce magness aurel qui m'a montré
la vidéo sur youtube c'est là que les
parents d'auguste habitants l'hiver en
été il habite une maison plus moderne
mais en hiver la vieille demeure et plus
pratique parce que les bêtes qui servent
de chauffage central
[Musique]
on va voir la maison natale ou à
utiliser
la vidéo
[Musique]
mais revenons aux armes c'est pas beau
ça
retour en arrière mais
tout a changé
je suis petit frère bus le dernier de la
famille et on a onze ans d'écart le
petit ici et bien c'est moi à oui
inchangé
j'ai pas vu mais j'ai grandi quoi la mbc
c'était tout mélicie
est au dessus il y avait la grande haie
à côté
le pâtis
séjour et à côté il y avait
six ou sept matches et attaché
avec nous dans la famille dans qu'il y
avait deux parents est latente rr en mer
à l'époque c'est presque une obligation
de prendre en charge des anciens vous
avez quel âge
78 la grand mère et la tante dormait à
l'écurie mais il y avait quand même une
cloison qui séparait les vaches et la
partie habitation
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la vie que
même au petit film à votre beauté et ce
pardon maintenant je pense qu'elle peut
gagner
vous pensez que c'est mieux parce que
c'est rigolo il y avait deux trois lits
par chambre et puis elles étaient
dispatchés dans plusieurs dents plus
haut bâtiment le soi quand on est arrivé
dans la chambre
il y avait un centimètre de givre sur
les murs dans s'amuse à gratter le mur
le livre tombe et il y en avait les
draps qui était humide avec l'onac en
outre ne pas vous traînez pas si jamais
on s'habille et en mentalité l'écurie
retrouver le chauffage naturel des
vaches on est là ou ailleurs en bonne
santé et où le froid concernent
[Musique]
dix mois qu'il prenait les initiatives
mon père était souvent dans les champs
donc s'il y avait des problèmes un peu
réglé avec le mesf et ressort juste il a
les tentatives et ja oui
les gens de la montagne sont
accueillants et il ouvre la porte à tout
le monde et partager facilement les les
lieux casse-croûte petit lavit
la clusaz national 20 s'était donné pour
tâche et n'a surtout pas pu l'être
enfants mais à l'occasion de
mes peines avoir sorti les boutons on
vivait des produits de la ferme le
beurre les fromages que de vagues de
chair et les viandes chaque gagnant dont
+ ère nouvelle de cochon
[Musique]
pas trop fatiguant à la longue
ça dure
des fois plus enfin ne surtout pas
s'arrêter de notre labeur c'est un tollé
général parce que sinon
tu es notre pays notre mais si ces
photos c'est votre pain oui oui c'est
que je voulais dire vous le faites vous
même oui bien sûr que je tenais
n'ont pas de billet du cul du sexe qui
permettait de faire notre pain au four
du village et encore beaucoup de
familles monsieur qui font leur petit
hôtel peu quand on est tous là
il faut voter moi 2000 par jour alors
tant pis pour le chercher pour loi
survient de dénis charge mais c'est le
montage et à saint-martin
une ride très bien très avalanche de
l'hiver il fallait nourrir touche tout
ce petit monde dans ma gêne à voir qui
de rien la vidéo me paraissait plus
simple plus concrète je trouve que
maintenant c'est sain peu plus chacun
pour soi avant c'était vraiment
l'entr'aide entre agriculteurs entre
gens m'aiment
ne serait-ce qu avec les villages à côté
parce que tu en penses mais l'union se
fait la force
l'accès au village
se faisait par la ruelle en pente
ici c'est le seul moyen d'accéder au
village
[Musique]
n'a pas été trop dur d'élever tous ces
enfants jeux
ainsi
qu'une autre à la campagne la c2 on
habitait comme on appelle surtout
maintenant pour les mettres aller à
l'école coup pour qu'il y ait métier
convenable par la suite si j'étais jeune
à leur place je ferais comme eux je suis
le dernier à aller à l'école ici après
gta ville arranger c'est un village à
côté
jusqu'au certificat d'études
il ya 16 ans je suis parti travailler
avec torres dans les remontées
mécaniques et toi pourquoi tu deviens
pas moniteur auguste
d'avoir center j'ai vu que je pouvais
arriver un peu plus alors j'ai pas
hésité à laisser les skis et
l'impression ça vous fait d'avoir un
fils à à l'université
j'ai l'impression
via une bonne impression
il puisse continuer ses études d'aller
jusqu'au bout je ne pouvais pas je
voulais pas
sollicité mes parents pour une aide
financière parce que je savais que il y
avait les fesses heures un bazar et qu'
il fallait
je me préférait faire plutôt que de le
voir prendre votre succession à la ferme
oh oui
c'est faire
nous depuis ma petite enfance j'étais
toujours obligé de me surpasser de de
lutter contre tous les problèmes posés
ravi de la montagne et
j'ai gardé le goût de l'effort j'ai
installé une salle une seule branche je
n'avais pas envisagé jusqu'à présent
c'était la médecine j'ai pensé que même
avec un bac philo en travaillant on
pouvait y arriver il a fallu que je
comble tous mes retards en maths
physique chimie
mais au final j'ai réussi du tout mes
goûts et toi tu souhaiterais exercer son
autorité de médecin vérifie
sur la neige tout près des halles quoi
j'ai été un médecin de montagne j'ai
réalisé une
centre médical publicitaire qui
préfigurait les actuels maison de santé
que j'ai financé sous sol j'ai apporté
beaucoup de de service réservé aux
spécialistes
pour justement répondre aux besoins une
fois que j'ai arrêté mon activité
j'ai voulu le besoin d'écrire un livre
médecine de proximité en alerte rouge
[Musique]
j'ai deux enfants et j'ai eu deux petits
enfants voir qui de toute façon ne ne
prendront pas le chemin de la médecine
apparemment
[Musique]
li terme de dire mieux avant moi
ne correspond à rien y a pas de moment
où on fait des choses mieux
qu'avant
le message que je pourrais faire passer
c'est que
rien est impossible
[Musique]